I know we've been a bit delayed arriving
but thank you all very much and I know
that it's been a productive day
and I want to
[Music]
sometimes they're just perfect you know
sometimes moments just Collide and you
go that
says what I want to say a glass crashing
as Kamala Harris begins Her speech it's
November 22nd 2022 that's a lot of twos
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
we are live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and Blaze TV uh share subscribe tap the
notification Bell if you haven't I don't
know if you've heard about this but
things in the big Tech world are very
weird you never know when the hammer is
going to drop so if you have not
subscribed please go ahead and do that
and most importantly uh you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com you can sign up
absolutely free you can throw in a
couple bucks if you want to engage a bit
more but that way we have direct
communication I can send you a push
notification on my phone you get all
sorts of bonus stuff and all that good
stuff today we're going to continue what
we started yesterday which is a little
more of a dive into
the culture War rather than just the
race horse politics part of all of this
and one of the things that I wanted to
show you related to the culture War
today and you guys know it because you
are the wisest audience in all of the
digital space is how the media
manufactures a completely inaccurate
narrative in order to advance their
obvious political agenda which always
happens to be a leftist sort of big
government One World Government agenda
sometimes they retract stories that they
screw up in sometimes they don't and
usually if they retract a story uh it's
years later and it's too late because
the horse has left the barn the ship has
sailed and it's not just that they lie
about these things and then maybe
retract or maybe don't retract if that
often they'll create a whole new story
so you completely forget about the lies
in the past and that leaves us those of
us that are you know functioning
somewhat functioning in society we're
all characters in their video game
basically because there were so
bludgeoned with lies all the time so
that's what we're going to do uh for the
most part today and and the big lie I
know they like to talk about the big lie
is Donald Trump denying the results of
the election but really the big lie over
the past say two and a half years has
been what has happened with this Hunter
Biden laptop because two and a half
years ago roughly it was uh Hunter Biden
crack addict Hunter Biden who am I to
judge but crack addict Hunter Biden
dropped off his laptop at a laptop
repair shop it eventually made its way
uh the content of the DAT of the laptop
made its way to the New York Post the
New York Post reported on it the New
York Post which has been a place of
Journalism for over a hundred years and
suddenly Twitter said no no no no no no
no no you cannot report on this story
you cannot link to this story we're
going to delete accounts that are
talking to the story we're going to
Shadow ban you and suppress you if you
try to privately share this New York
Post story on Twitter meaning in your
direct messages your private messages
not even publicly what's going on on
Twitter we are going to not allow those
links to be pasted we are going to
suspend the New York Post account
and yes guys guess what Flash Forward
two and a half years later and you've
known it all along but now mainstream
media is finally catching on yeah the
laptop was real the info is real and uh
we're gonna certainly find out a whole
bunch more about it now that people are
finally paying attention so let's flash
back to three years ago because it's not
just two and a half years ago in the
laptop and the New York Post story was
wiped off Twitter it was even happening
a little bit before that when people
started talking about what was going on
with this thing here's Fox news's Peter
Ducey a guy that I can actually call a
journalist without without having to use
the air quotes uh questioning Joe Biden
about the hunter Biden scandal which
obviously the laptop has some info on
meaning that he was working for this
Ukrainian Energy company making a lot of
money didn't have any skills was a crack
addict
Etc vice president how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to myself
here's what I know I know Trump deserves
to be investigated he is violating every
basic Norm of a president you should be
asking him the question why is he on the
phone with a foreign leader trying to
intimidate a foreign leader if that's
what happened that's appears what
happened you should be looking at Trump
Trump's doing this because he knows I'll
beat him like a drum and he's using the
abuse of power and every element of the
the presidency to try to do something to
smear me everybody looked at this and
everybody's looked at it said there's
nothing there ask the right questions
okay so you can note the anger and the
righteous indignation of Joe Biden the
faux righteous indignation because
everything he said there was a lie first
off this idea that he never spoke to his
son about business he never spoke to his
son about Phoenix is your dad have any
idea what you're doing all day long do
you tell him does he know where you work
uh you know I'm pretty sure my dad knows
what I'm doing like yeah yes that's what
you do that is what you do you tell you
Talk Amongst a father and son or a
mother and daughter or even a mother and
son or a daughter and father and you
talk about what you're doing all day
long but Joe Biden even though his son
is working for this Ukrainian Energy
company and he has no literally no
expertise Consulting for them and he's
making a [ __ ] ton of money and his dad
just happens to be vice president at the
time they didn't have they just never
talked about this stuff except it turns
out that they did because there's
voicemails that have exposed that but
let's just back up a little bit and just
do Hunter Biden laptop 101 for those of
you that are just catching up we got a
little info here from the daily wire a
year-long exploration of Hunter Biden's
laptop has yielded a 630 page report
that its authors say document
459 violations of state and federal laws
and regulations by President Joe Biden's
son and his business partners in 2020
days before the election the New York
Post published news of the laptop's
existence as well as Bombshells from it
but social media suppressed the story
after the FBI had warned companies of
so-called misinformation the report
which reviewed the laptop's emails
videos calendar items photographs phone
records financial documents and more but
also provided context and explanation
serves as a Rosetta Stone of white and
blue collar crime under the patina of
the Delaware way the report says we were
able to illuminate previously convoluted
Network webs of the people leading the
charge for Global governance cutting
through shell companies and middlemen
crimes Hunter Biden allegedly committed
included serving as an agent for foreign
entities without disclosing it tax fraud
and falsifying business documents the
alleged crimes also include prostitution
non-consensual pornography and
distribution of Nar narcotics Now look
for any of you that saw there was a day
where a lot of the images were dropping
on Twitter and elsewhere and then they
were just like it was incredible
watching it happen you could watch
accounts get blown apart in real time
all the pictures of him with the
prostitutes and with the crack or the
cocaine or whatever it was and he's
admitted to he was sniffing the carpet
looking for cheese cheese crack
I always forget you smoke crack and you
snort cocaine it's hard to catch up with
these bidens you know anyway obviously
now it turns out that the laptop was
real and the the interesting part of
what I just read you is that the FBI was
telling social media companies don't
allow this stuff to be posted because of
misinformation that is a direct
violation of the First Amendment okay
you are allowed to share misinformation
look MSNBC is still on television right
you're allowed to share misinformation I
prefer that you didn't I try not to but
I'm sure I have you know it happens
every now and again but either way the
the FBI saying to a tech company don't
let people post this and then it all
turns out to be true two and a half
years later after they got the result in
the election that they wanted right
because Biden did become president I
mean you guys get it uh all right here
is video of Peter Ducey again a rare
journalist who I don't have to use air
quotes around ask asking our black
lesbian press secretary Corrine
Jean-Pierre back in July on New
Revelations related to Joe's involvement
the laptop
Etc why is there a voicemail of the
president talking to his son about his
overseas business dealings if the
president has said he's never spoken to
his son about his overseas business
series well first I'll say that uh what
the president said stands so if he if
that's what the president said that that
is what stands and second secondly
but secondly secondly business dealings
and he says I think you're clear how is
that not him talking to his son about
his overseas business dealings we're not
from this Podium I am not going to talk
about alleged materials from the laptop
she's just the worst I mean I've said it
before but like she actually makes sake
look good at her job so you got what
just had what happened there so we
showed you the video of three years ago
when Joe Biden is telling the same Guy
Peter Ducey I never what was the line
never spoke to my son about business now
of course that's a lie if you speak to
your child about anything occasionally
work might come up so what do you do for
a living son barisma that's it Ukraine a
lot of money you're not qualified you're
smoking crack you must some of that
might have come up right some of it
might have come up
but then you there's a voicemail they
didn't play it right there but there is
a voicemail that exists I think we
played it on the show once or twice back
in the day where Biden is asking him
about his business dealings and a report
that was coming out of the New York
Times related to all of this now what's
really interesting about all of this is
the way the media coordinated to kill
the story so the FBI tells social media
hey don't talk about that thing and then
mainstream media carries the water to
continue the laundering of the lies
here's a beautiful compilation of
mainstream media dismissing the New York
Post Hunter Biden story which in case
you're not following along turned out
all to be true go ahead
no no I probably best I don't
this is really one of the stupidest
October surprises I've ever seen it
helps to really view this as
storytelling not so much as news
coverage but as political entertainment
NPR explained we don't want to waste our
time on stories that are not really
stories who even thought to make that
story up it's a story that many
intelligence experts say has all the
Hallmarks of a foreign interference
campaign it looks like it's tied to
Vladimir Putin in Moscow this is a
Russian intelligence disinformation
campaign it's a foreign intelligence
operation foreign intelligence operation
Russian intelligence Rudy Giuliani was
not fed passively Russian disinformation
he ordered it off the menu this is a
classic example of the right wing media
machine and he's an image of a scandal
he's not and he's taking of course he is
lastly we should note Hunter Biden isn't
running for president that argument has
been debunked there is no evidence that
Joe Biden did anything wrong for all we
know these emails are made up it just
lacks credibility okay
and start doing that verification no
we're not going to do your work for you
Character Matters it matters tell them
the truth matters
being a good person matters
[Laughter]
we've managed to stay roughly saying
these last couple years I commend you
I'd like to give you a gold star or a
little sticker that you could put on the
lapelier jacket because if you didn't
fall for all of this I didn't fall for
all of it I don't think these people in
this room fell for it I don't think you
fell for it but millions and millions of
people fall for these things they fall
for this they fall for Donald Trump very
fine people on both sides they fall for
all of the covid stuff and vaccines work
and get your eighth booster and it makes
sense to lock kids out of school people
have fallen for all of these things
that's why I'm doing the show today the
way that I am because if you don't look
back like everyone in there whether it's
Brian stelter who actually did get fired
or whether it's Brian Williams on MSNBC
remember Brian Williams he was the NBC
Nightly News host and then they caught
him in a lie so what happens at NBC you
don't get fired you just move over to
the the double a network MSNBC uh any of
those people the CNN hosts that were
talking about it they all should be
fired that's not cancel culture you
people are in are all all do in
negligence in your duty to to report the
truth your activists who protect a
political party in a political class as
opposed to telling the truth you know
who tried to tell the truth about this
thing you're not going to believe this
one
it's the orange guy that's right Donald
Trump here he is two years ago on 60
Minutes with Leslie Stahl trying to talk
about this situation and just watch her
unbelievable it's this I think it's one
of the biggest scandals I've ever seen
and you don't cover it biggest you want
to talk about well because it can't be
verified you want to talk about
insignificant things I'm telling you of
course it can be verified excuse me they
found the laptop Leslie Leslie
what can't be verified the laptop why do
you say that because even the family
hasn't the family on the laptop
he's gone into hiding for five days he's
gone into hiding he's preparing for your
debate oh it's taken him five days to
prepare I doubt it I doubt it okay all
right
how did Donald Trump somehow know that
the laptop was real there were plenty of
people online before they were getting
booted from Twitter and elsewhere that
knew that it was real my feeling from
the beginning and you can go back and
check my tweets on this thing once I
started talking about it was I don't
know maybe it's real let's kind of find
out but the fact that the whole machine
is crashing down on the people that are
talking about it kind of makes me think
that it is real because that's what
happens right if you tell the truth
they're going to take you out
story of humanity so that's interesting
because that was on 60 Minutes two years
ago and 60 Minutes is a part of CBS well
you're not going to believe this guys
but here's CBS yesterday confirming
everything that Leslie Stahl said wasn't
true two years ago and as Republicans
take control of the house Hunter Biden
the president's son will be a target for
investigations and that means data from
a laptop reported to belong to Biden
could be crucial to the investigatory
process CBS News has obtained its data
not through a third party or political
operative but directly from the source
who told us they provided it to the FBI
under subpoena and we commissioned an
independent forensic review to determine
its authenticity senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Harris joins us
now with what we've found Catherine I'm
very interested good morning Good
morning Tony these house Republican
investigations are coming in that would
be a challenge for the White House as we
head into 2023 and 2024 the laptop data
we had analyzed showed no evidence it
was faked or tampered with
okay so congratulations to CBS which two
and a half years later is starting to
catch on to exactly guys exactly what
the New York Post reported on two and a
half years ago what the mainstream media
does what corporate press does is they
put truth on A Time release pill right
so you swallow it but you don't get
truth till two and a half years later
once they've figured out how to
re-engineer society and make you think
all sorts of crazy things and win the
elections the way they want them to be
won then suddenly the truth starts
leaking out all anyone at CBS had to do
that anchor there I'm very interested in
this well okay anchor on CBS did you
think of maybe picking up the phone and
calling somebody at New York Post two
and a half years ago and saying hey New
York Post guy you guys put out this
really controversial thing I'd be
interested in knowing what your sources
were and maybe then I could report on it
so what's the mainstream media also
focused on right now well now they
realize that Trump is going to become a
problem for them again right and I think
there's a little bit of a catch-22 right
now with their relationship with Trump
on one hand they love Trump because
Trump delivers clicks Trump delivers
eyeballs on the other hand they hate him
because he's you know orange Hitler and
then I guess there's a more than it's a
triple-sided coin because then on the
other side of that is I think they
actually really feel fear DeSantis more
than him and if Trump goes after
DeSantis they'll be very happy for that
so they'll be telling you that orange
Hitler is actually a good guy for taking
out the guy that's the new Hitler it's
all bananas uh but what is going on at
CBS well yesterday uh there was an
interview with Mike Pence former VP Mike
Pence that was played where they asked
him about January 6 and they asked about
Trump and all these things and you can
see here the panel is very upset that
Pence does not have trumped Arrangement
syndrome I'm so fascinated by what the
vice president has to say because he
still doesn't seem
um willing to just totally condemn a
full-throated condemnation of Donald
Trump this was your this was your
running mate your partner and he's
encouraging people basically to kill you
he could have been killed that day I
really do believe that Mike Pence is
very careful here I want to make sure
that we point out that the January 6th
committee does have two Republicans on
it Republican leaders chose not to
appoint more but in condemning the
actions and calling the former president
Reckless and saying he was part of the
problem these are all things he said to
me it's going right up to the line
without completely separating from the
part of the Republican party that's very
supportive of the former president the
Trump True Believers we call them on
Election night I think most parents
would say if my child was in the midst
of this how could you not be full of
Rage
so Gayle King right there and Gail King
is on television because I guess she's
Oprah's best friend that's how she got
the gig right Oprah used to bring her on
this is my best friend Gail and everyone
was like what's she doing there and then
she was like somebody give Gail a job
and now Gail's got a job uh at uh CBS
over there uh she says that Trump was
encouraging people to kill Pence she
says I really believe that now I'm not
defending every single thing that Trump
did leading up to January 6. he
certainly never called for violence also
there was no plan to kill Mike Pence
nobody brought weapons people are still
in jail over it or held in indefinite
detention all sorts of complete nonsense
there was no Insurrection they keep
using the word Insurrection and
Insurrection you would have had some
plans guys here's what we're going to do
and then we're going to take over
Congress and then we're going to execute
these people and no they had nothing
they were literally taking pictures in
Nancy Pelosi's office with their feet on
the desk and the guy with the crazy horn
hat and everything else but the
mainstream media they have to keep you
angry why would they want to keep you
angry why would CBS on the same day that
they're finally reporting on the laptop
why would they also want to make you
then think oh but Donald Trump also was
trying to kill Mike Pence it's because
it turns out Trump was right turns out
Trump was right about the laptop so what
else is the media prioritizing right now
well over at the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC there's this
guy we've played some videos of him
before it's hard to believe he's a real
person he appears to be a villain from
Gotham City Batman is looking for this
guy he's hanging out with Two-Face and
The Riddler and the Penguin and give me
one more Bane give me one more Joker
give me one more poison ivy thank you
his name is Anand garada
something like that and uh he is very
upset that billionaires exist and I
wonder if he had the power as a Gotham
villain what he would do to billionaires
because guys like Elon Musk are
defending Free Speech appears to be a
game to him but letting Donald Trump
back in their room Kanye was posting uh
again yesterday as well
um what does it all add up to you know
first of all I think something we often
forget As Americans is that billionaires
exist as a class of people who have that
much money at our Collective pleasure
right it is a policy choice to allow
some people to accumulate that much
money hundreds of billions of dollars in
the case of people in the United States
before everybody has the chance to live
with dignity he brings back Donald Trump
who's who's kind of unleashed the the
the the white nationalist demons in this
country uh on that platform and off in
ways that are obviously have caused us
to come to the brink of losing our
democracy Elon musk's Big Ideas let's
bring him back he's gutted the company
photos of him from the company at a
so-called code meeting show that there's
basically like no women left working
around him it's just a big sausage fest
in there working you know in the team
that he has remaining around him their
existence as as billionaires is sort of
antithetical to our flourishing as a
democracy first off I feel like I have
to apologize to the Riddler and to the
Joker and Poison Ivy and Bane and some
of these other people these were
criminal masterminds these were people
with two-faced you may not like
everything that they're doing they all
had problems a lot of them going back to
their childhood but they they had some
insight into the world you know and it
was misguided and it often led to murder
and Mayhem staying in Arkham Asylum all
that stuff
um Arkham Asylum that's a good reference
you got that one right you definitely
didn't go you got it you got it wow all
right
um anyway they I should not compare them
to that completely crazy person on MSNBC
let's just go through some of that first
of all billionaires exist at our at our
pleasure you know billionaires I know
one or two billionaires
um I don't know they're working and
they're creating things you don't just
become a billionaire by doing nothing
you create Industries you create
incredible products you create things
like Tesla or like PayPal or you create
railroads back in the day like you do
these things which then create hundreds
of thousands and often millions of jobs
and you allow all sorts of people to
have some Independence over their life
so the idea that you just want to take
out that those are the real problem if
you right now if that guy and none the
evil Gotham villain I don't want to give
an evil Gotham Bill and an idea but if
he took out the top 10 billionaires in
America if you just took them out and
took all of their money and then just
gave all of their money to America first
off it would do nothing on the debt but
putting that aside like if you just
spread that money out in a year from now
there would still be homelessness there
would still be all the problems and
people would be pissing all this money
away and you have to work to earn
something we can discuss whether there
are tricks and games that they play and
all of those things on the margins fine
but the problem is not the billionaires
it's the government in the first place
that's one thing he said then Trump
unleashed the white nationalist demons
which I'm pretty sure he's the evil
Gotham guy here with the white
nationalist demons that does seem like
an evil character uh and then of course
we were on the brink of losing democracy
again they had no plans one guy had the
Lego set which turned out it didn't even
he didn't even bring it or something uh
and then he's going on about this
picture so Elon Musk posted a picture
it's like 1am in the Twitter office a
couple days ago and he's got some bunch
of programmers around him and this
picture went viral because it appeared I
don't know there were maybe 30 people
around him and it appeared that there
were no women it turns out there were at
least four women that you just have to
kind of find them and it's San Francisco
so everyone's kind of a he she man woman
or whatever so you got to kind of look
around somebody's shoulder and then you
spot a chick or whatever but either way
Elon didn't you think Elon went in there
like dude guys I'm gonna fire all the
chicks like enough of the chicks you
know no he went in and he said are you
doing your job do you want to work here
many people who quit on their own they
probably happen to be women many people
that uh that were not doing their job
very well they might have been women
these people are completely bananas and
I hope I didn't give that evil God the
villain any ideas anyway what else is
going on here well the entire machine is
not happy with uh Elon Musk right now
because he's allowing people back on
Twitter he allowed Donald Trump back on
Twitter he allowed Sargon of a Cod this
is an old uh old school uh YouTuber who
was one of the first people when I was
leaving the left like eight years ago
he was one of the guys that was on
YouTube like I'm a liberal let this have
gone crazy he was eventually kicked off
patreon and that's what caused me and
Jordan Peterson to leave patreon which
ultimately led me to building locals
emerging with Rumble so I have great I'm
very excited that Carl Benjamin who's
also been on the show if you haven't
seen my interviews with him over the
years that he is now back on Twitter but
anyway the entire machine is crashing
down on Elon Musk because he's allowing
more voices to be heard let's not forget
what was it about 10 days ago that a
bunch of tick-tockers and Tick Tock is a
Chinese app designed to data mine
Americans and everyone except the
Chinese although they're they're doing a
different version of data mining when it
comes to their own people
um a bunch of tick tockers went to the
White House and remember one of the
tick-tockers asked Joe Biden what he
should do about Elon Musk anyway Becker
news has some info on what Joe Biden's
up to related to Mr Elon President Joe
Biden on November 10th threatened Elon
Musk with a National Security review
after taking over Twitter and vowing to
implement new safeguards for free speech
on the social media platform I think
that Elon musk's cooperation and or
technical relationships with other
countries is worthy of being looked at
whether or not he's doing anything
inappropriate my God that sentence I'm
not suggesting that I'm suggesting that
it's worth being looked at Biden told
reporters on Wednesday it wasn't
reporters that he was talked to it was a
bunch of tick tockers when asked how he
would put musk's deal under scrutiny the
president said there's lots of ways do
you see how evil this is and how
pernicious and nefarious the government
can be he doesn't know that elon's done
anything wrong but we should look into
his businesses by the way Ed Markey
who's a senator also said that we should
look into Elon musk's businesses so Elon
Musk buys Twitter he says I'm going to
try to have it a little bit more open
for free speech and then the government
starts coming in and says we're going to
see what you're doing over there with
Tesla we're going to see what you're
doing over there with SpaceX we're going
to see what you're doing over there with
the boring company and with neurolink
and starlink and everything else this is
Mafia Style
fascist tactics that they are doing on
this guy so the guy needs our support
right now I get it he's a billionaire
and maybe he's just got a rocket waiting
in his backyard and they're going to
come for him one day and he's just going
to take his family to Mars and God bless
him for it and Elon I'll come with you
um but this is this is crazy stuff the
idea we don't know that he's done
anything but we're sure going to look we
should we should probably look around
you know we I don't know if that guy
murdered anybody but we should probably
subpoena his laptop we should probably
go through all this stuff how am I
supposed to know if he murdered anybody
unless I check all the stuff
ridiculous so what else is going on here
what else is going on here well there
was actually a horrific uh shooting at a
nightclub in Colorado so I'm going to
link this to sort of everything that
we're talking about here but a little
bit of info on that from the daily wire
a gunman opened fire inside a game
nightclub in Colorado just before
midnight Saturday killing five people
while at least 25 others reported
injuries authorities said the Carnage
are cured inside Club Q in Colorado
Springs which describes itself online as
an adult oriented gay and lesbian
nightclub hosting theme nights such as
karaoke drag shows and DJs the suspected
gunman was detained and taken into
custody shortly after the attack so let
me just address this and then you'll see
how I'm linking this everything else as
far as I know at the moment we don't
know anything about this guy's motives
I've heard some people say he was a
closeted gay person I've had the media
is all running around saying he was a
crazy right-winger and they're trying to
connect it to you know conservatives and
all that stuff we just don't know yet
what we do know is one very bad person
for whatever the reason might be and it
obviously had something to do with
mental health because you don't just
walk into a nightclub or into a school
or into a church and shoot a bunch of
innocent people unless you're mentally
unwell we know that he is responsible
for his actions but you guys know this
is 2022 and on social media everyone
uses this for their own political
purposes here is Chicago mayor Laurie
Lightfoot
throw me that tweet I'm sick of this
[ __ ] how many people need to be murdered
how many lives torn apart until it
actually stops we don't have to live
like this and we don't have to die like
this that's what Lori Lightfoot said now
uh first off I just it goes without
saying that I have nothing but sympathy
and empathy and thoughts for the for the
families of the five people that were
killed the people that were injured okay
fine Lori Lightfoot saying this that
she's sick of it she can't believe that
this happens and there's hate and all of
those things Lori Lightfoot is the mayor
of Chicago so I said to Phoenix before
the show let's research how many people
were killed in Chicago her City this
weekend because she's very upset about
Colorado Springs five people were killed
well you know how many people were
killed in Chicago this weekend five also
five yeah five were killed 60 injured by
gun violence so that's uh that's
actually pretty low for Chicago and uh
from WTTW news let's get the update on
the year in killings in Chicago yeah
about 450 people as of September 1st so
it's got to be closer to about 500 now
so about 500 people have been killed by
gun violence in Chicago her City she's
doing jack [ __ ] about that uh Chicago
has some of the and Illinois has some of
the most stringent gun laws possible she
doesn't want to talk about that because
that's black people killing black people
frankly I don't care about anyone's skin
color or their gender or their sexuality
when it comes to murdering people you
are a bad person if you murder people
regardless of actually your motives even
whether you're racist or not if you're
just crazy or if you're racist or you're
whatever you might be but the media's
gut reaction that's why I'm linking this
story is not only to blame conservatives
but to also defend drag queen Story Hour
because they're right because this bar
had drag queens there so they somehow
want to link this to drag queen Story
Hour and there's been that's been in the
news endlessly and Non-Stop and they
want to blame conservatives I have never
once heard a conservative say go into a
bar and kill a bunch of gay people go
kill some trans people generally they're
saying some of them might say I
personally believe in traditional
marriage but there aren't many people
that are are fighting off same-sex
marriage at this point
um it is it is the law of the land and
even before The Supreme Court went in
and decided that it was happening state
to state which probably was the better
way for it to happen through the
legislative process rather than the
courts but that's somewhat of a moot
point now but I think something like 26
States had already legalized it was
happening every week you may remember
that about seven years ago or so but you
can see what the media is doing here
they want they hear oh a shooting at a
place that has drag queens there's drag
queens drag queens are always teaching
young kids how to read for some reason I
don't know why drag queens never go to
actuary conventions drag queens never go
to the Dental Association of America and
perform for those people drag queens
don't seem to go to the shoe salesman
convention in Sheboygan Wisconsin they
don't seem to do that they only can
perform for children apparently
here's the televised mental institution
MSNBC with racist Joy Reed and she
actually aired a clip of drag queen
Story Hour and I don't think this
segment went exactly how she intended or
just to go on because I don't think most
people have ever seen one I've been to
one with kids there with like kids there
I want to show you guys what drag queen
story hours look like because there was
a drag show at that was supposed to be
at this club uh when this attack
happened I just want those who don't
know what they look like to see what one
looks like this is cut two please play
this
the hair so a lot of drag queens have
really big big big hair so the hair on
the drag queen goes up up up so you can
put your hands on your head like this
and go up up up
so the hair on the drag queen goes up up
up up up up up up up up up up up up the
hair on the drag queen goes up up up all
through the town good job
and you know it it makes me sad Brandon
that that scares right wing people so
much that they would try to ban it or
your Governor sued people over it and
then people act surprised when there's
violence against people who are trans
and lgbtq okay A little throwaway first
Joy Reid years ago on her blog used to
go after Charlie Crist all the time
because he was a closeted gay Republican
so she deleted all those posts and then
pretended that somebody hacked into her
blog but she has a history of Anthony
gayness herself now I want to be clear
about one thing here there's a
difference between drag queens and trans
people what you saw there was a dude
dressed up as a chick I have no evidence
I was told by Joy Reid that that's a
drag queen not a trans person so that is
a guy who identifies as a guy who
dresses up like a chicken for some
reason wants to read children's stories
to children and why would you want a
five-year-old to have to look at that
thing and think about what is going on
here what what why would you want to
enter into look as an adult you can live
your life any way you to see fit and
it's ultimately up to a parent obviously
to decide what they want to see and what
they want their child to see and what
they wanted them to be affected by and
all of those things but there's obvious
like it's just so obvious it's
ridiculous so that but I just want to
make the point that there is a
difference between a drag queen and a
trans person who fundamentally feels
that they are in the wrong body and then
often goes through the the surgeries to
transition into the other gender this
would be someone like Kailyn Caitlyn
Jenner right Bruce Jenner who became
Caitlyn Jenner uh Bruce did the whole
thing Bruce chopped Bruno Bruce added
the boobs chopped the Wang Bruce is
living as a woman I I'll it's okay good
to go okay Kaelyn it's all good but that
does not mean you have to infect the
minds of children with this stuff and I
would recommend that you read uh what's
the Abigail schreier's book um sorry I'm
blanking on the name uh great book uh
what is it irreversible damage thank you
irreversible damage by Abigail schreier
who I've had on the show how it is
becoming a social contagion that
suddenly trans the amount of kids who
identify as trans is exploding usually
it's young girls who want to transition
to boys and then they realize a year or
two later after sometimes they've taken
these puberty blockers and all sorts of
other stuff that oh no it was just a
little bit of a phase or it was a social
contagion remember the movie Heathers it
was a social contagion that everyone
starts acting the exact same way
but there is a bizarre
movement in mainstream media to
normalize drag queens with kids again
why don't drag queens okay so they do
events at gay nightclubs okay that's
fine
and then why don't they do events with
anyone else other than kids again the
actuaries the accountants the dentists
the shoe salesmen whoever it might be
why doesn't the NBA bring in a bunch of
drag queens to do team building with the
Knicks
bizarre right it has to be with kids
well here's this guy uh Ben Collins he
is the dystopia beat reporter at NBC it
is the most ironic this guy's like this
is like reliable sources Brian stelter
level irony when it comes to the title
of what you do the dystopia beat
reporter I mean he's all about dystopia
and here he is you can see he wants to
normalize drag queens with kids for some
reason I don't know why how significant
are those two dates yeah and also hours
before uh what they called an all ages
Drag Brunch which is probably the number
one target of these uh anti-lgbtq
um events recently like for example the
proud boys will go and protest any Drag
Brunch any um any drag Story Hour
anything that a child might go to meet a
drag queen not you know just to show
them that they're human beings and
people they talk they go there and they
they read Dr Seuss there they read
regular books but it's read by a drag
queen and they you know they have
breakfast uh it is not some hypersexual
event but that's what it's viewed as on
the far right oh it's not some
hypersexual event when you have an adult
man dressed as a woman with giant boobs
and crazy lipstick talking about her
hair there's nothing sexual about that
man these people are such [ __ ] freaks
pardon my friendship there goes the
modernization see I'm not making money
on the show today that's how importantly
I that's how deeply I feel about all
this nonsense so for some reason he
wants kids other people's kids to meet
with these drag queens I don't know why
but it continues and NBC here's Brandon
uh sorry Brandy zadroni I'm pretty sure
she blocked me on Twitter uh and she
also wants drag queens and kids to be
very very normal
LGBT community has always been a subject
of hatred for a certain brand of Fringe
kind of person right but something
happened in March and April of this year
and in March and April this year as the
far right wing conservatives sort of got
over CRT or critical race Theory they
needed a new Boogeyman and they left on
lgbtq community members specifically
trans people they're doctors their
caregivers libraries that had books that
were LGBT LGBT focused drag time Story
Hour where a drag queen would come it
was a ubiquitous in libraries all over
the country had a drag queen would come
read a story it was fun the kids loved
it and then also some sort of friendly
friendly drag shows it would be on a
Sunday brunch you could bring the kids
they'd see a show
in fact I just want to make a couple
things clear here first off I happen to
be married to a dude I have two kids
downstairs
um I change diapers this morning
um I have nothing to do with these
people okay I don't want to take my
children to drag queen Story Hour
they're never going to go I remember 20
years ago going to a gay bar one night
and it was drag night and it was vile
and disgusting and it was endless sex
jokes and gross and dildos
but okay some people are into it go be
into it when you're above 18. why what
is the necessity that's the thing it's
this odd Obsession and necessity to
bring it to children that is the weird
thing there that's why these these
letters and when I did that interview
with Jordan Peterson about gay marriage
we repeatedly got into this this
collectivist idea of the letters the
LGBT community the lesbian gay bisexual
trans Q whatever the hell that is plus I
have nothing to do with any of these
people I represent no one other than
myself I think that's how most gay
people feel uh I think that's how most
straight people feel is there a straight
Community you're straight you better
think about yo you two you guys are
straight right you guys think the same
on everything oh you guys do but all
right well you both love the Reuben
report we know that much
anyway this Brandy's the dronesi uh she
continued because you got to find
somebody to blame when bad people do
things what you got to do is you gotta
figure out a way to blame the people you
don't like and of course that's always
going to involve Tucker Carlson and in
this case uh there's the famous Twitter
account unsuspended now lives of tick
tock Brandy explain that when you hear
that your reaction to it and then kind
of walk us through how rhetoric online
rhetoric from politicians can ultimately
trickle down into real life and seeing
examples of what happened over the
weekend if there is a pipeline it starts
from some smaller accounts online like
Libs of tick tock it moves to the
right-wing blogosphere and then it ends
up on Tucker Carlson or it ends up out
of a right-wing politician's mouth and
it's a really dangerous cycle
bananas these people are so bananas so
for those of you that don't know how the
internet works people post all sorts of
things and then people started talking
about all sorts of things and sharing
all sorts of things and then yes
occasionally they do trickle up when
there's enough people talking about a
certain thing or enough people have
exposed a certain thing or shared video
of something then it might get to say a
Tucker Carlson and Tucker Carlson might
go boy that is awfully interesting the
libs of tick tock account by the way
they do not instigate hate they have
never as I have seen it is run by a
woman who has since been doxed by by
many quote-unquote journalists they know
she never says go hurt these people she
never I don't even think she says these
people are evil or anything to that
effect she basically reposts their posts
so all of these trans teachers and these
gender queer asexual penis vagina
teachers they go make their own videos
the penis vagina teachers that's in
seventh grade when I took Health that's
what they we called him uh
they put their own videos usually crying
in their cars uh talking about how
they're trying to indoctrinate these
kids they usually don't say the word
indoctrination but they say we're trying
to teach these kids about gender and
sexuality and fluidity and then they
post them on Tick Tock or wherever it
might be and then all she does is repost
them that's what she does so if anything
she's acting as a journalist oh here's a
person saying a certain something I'm
just showing people what it is okay so
that's just how it is but you see this
is another reason why they're so upset
by the Elon Musk thing because little
accounts share things and then it gets
to Big Tucker Carlson and we can't have
little people sharing the truth because
little people are the fertilizer for the
thing that grows and that's Tucker
Carlson anyway here's video of former
FBI assistant director for
counterintelligence I love this guy's
name this is Frank fuguzi okay right out
of Goodfellas blaming Lauren bobert and
Tucker Carlson for the shooting he's a
consumer of the people we just rattled
off from Lauren bobert to Tucker Carlson
let's get it out let's get it out at
trial let's expose it for what it is
name it and shame it he's a consumer of
these people and those people should
face civil consequences from the victims
that's vile and disgusting and
anti-American there is no evidence that
this Shooter had anything to do with
Lauren bobert or Tucker Carlton and even
if it turned out that he watched Tucker
Carlson unless Tucker Carlson directly
caught somebody get out there and shoot
these people then you cannot blame
Tucker Carlson right and of course
Tucker Carlson does not want trans
people or gay people or anybody to be
shot you were allowed to have some
standards of decency in society and you
have to decide what those standards are
for yourself so Tucker Carlson does
interview Libs of tick tock Libs of tick
tock does repost the very words that
these people are saying in the first
place uh but the idea that there would
be civil penalties for that so what
happens should we have civil penalties
for all the people that all day long
call Donald Trump a Nazi it's pretty you
know what if someone shot Donald Trump
because you guys have been calling him a
Nazi
you see you see how this thing works
uh here is video of a pulse Club
Survivor so pulse was the gay club I
think in Orlando about five years ago
that was shot up it turned out to be an
islamist an Isis member but everyone
wanted to make it seem like he had been
radicalized by the Republicans and
everything else and I think something
like it was it was more than a dozen
people were killed if I'm not mistaken
uh this is a clip from we showed you the
joy read thing earlier uh he continues
and of course yes who are you going to
blame if you're in Florida and a
shooting happens in Colorado yeah you
blame DeSantis the news that this has
happened again uh in another city just
like it happened to you and your friends
I'm just going to let you give us your
reaction
yeah thank you Joy uh and I'm I'm angry
tonight I I'm angry because this is what
we warned would happen this is what we
warned would be the inevitable
consequence of unmitigated unbridled
hate in this country now you just saw
what's been happening for the last few
years right wing grifters including
politicians like Ron DeSantis and Greg
Abbott they've been spewing this vile
hateful rhetoric about lgbtq people
they've been trafficking in some of the
oldest darkest tropes against our
community they've been accusing us of
posing a threat to Children simply
because we exist
I know we can all become Jaded by this
stuff so first off I I have sympathy for
the guy that lost his friends in that
shooting I can only imagine what a
horrific event it would be to be at a
place that was shot up and all of those
things this has nothing to do with
Rhonda said this this has nothing to do
with Greg Abbott Ron DeSantis does not
hate gay people do you know that when we
announced we were having kids the
DeSantis campaign sent us two onesies
for the babies okay when when I met
Casey DeSantis a couple months back at
an event I told her you know we're
trying to find an OB GYN for our
surrogates here uh and she gave me two
OB gyns that I should look into we ended
up using one of them that's how much
they hate gay people okay but what does
MSNBC do they they this is why Ben
Shapiro's facts don't care about your
feelings thing matters it is irrelevant
what this guy thinks about that shooting
you you should bring on a reporter to
talk about the shooting in Colorado who
has some ins who has some insight into
what happened there did we find out
anything about the shooter do we know
what the security procedures were at the
event how did did he get radicalized
perhaps okay that would be news right
now I know MSNBC is not doing news to
bring on someone to say oh you were at
something that happened five years ago
how do you feel about the thing that
happened over there and it just so
happens to fit the narrative that we're
constantly pushing that conservatives
are all mean and evil and racist and
homophobic it is complete complete
nonsense I just did Halloween here for
the first time in Florida my gay family
with my husband and two kids all dressed
up like skeletons out and about and the
neighbors couldn't have been freaking
nicer if anything people are too nice I
find it a little irritating so I've done
to them people oh my God because they
realize oh my God because they suddenly
want to show you that they're not a
homophobia oh my God
all right anyway the point here is does
anyone at this point think that the
media is unbiased and fair this one is
just a gem this one is a gem uh Jennifer
Rubin now Jennifer Rubin a lot of people
online they say Dave that's your sister
you must be related to her I have looked
into trying to sue her for the name
Reuben I asked Elon Musk on Twitter
Twitter yesterday Elon Musk if there was
a way that perhaps I could fight Jen
Rubin in some sort of Thunderdome type
situation two men enter one man leaves
uh and then we the winner would keep the
name Reuben you know Tina Turner's
retired now I think she lives in
Switzerland but I'm pretty sure we could
get her involved you catching that
reference you're getting it yeah
um anyway Jen Rubin look at this so this
is uh two this is what is this a month
ago not no not even a month ago this is
just yeah it's just about a month ago on
10 26 22 here's what Jen Rubin wrote
DeSantis is unimpressive outside the
right wing media bubble then less than
one month later on November 21st 2022
just in the last couple days beware
DeSantis is as much a threat to America
as strong
these people are all insane and isn't
this what I've been saying right what
have I been saying for months now about
the Santa situation again we don't know
if the guy's even gonna run but they
need him to be worse than Trump and the
more that Trump will go after DeSantis
the more the media will like Trump
because DeSantis is the real threat
because he's Hitler with a calculator
right he's competent
all right we're about to finish up here
I have thoroughly enjoyed this show a
lot of references this show I really
busted out all the 80s and 90s stuff uh
here's Democrat activist uh Jake Tapper
over on CNN uh and then we thought this
would be a fun way to end this thing
because you know a lot of people feel
that this Red Wave didn't happen and it
was such a disaster for Republicans but
the simple truth is Republicans got uh
Congress back right they are already
looking into the hunter Biden laptop
thing there's a rumor that they're gonna
uh impeach mayorkas who's the health and
Homeland Security guy you know he's in
charge of health and Homeland Security
he's the one that's basically in charge
of the Border they're they're looking
into possibly impeaching him I think
Kevin McCarthy hinted at that this
morning
um so there there certainly was no Blue
Wave and there it does seem like
Republicans are maybe kind of getting
that what is what does Joe Biden always
say the ramrod the Republican ramrod is
here people so anyway here's uh Democrat
activist Jake Tapper on CNN talking to
new house Democrat leader Hakeem
Jeffries reminding him that no you guys
didn't really crush it this time I'm
actually you were kind of defeated I
want to ask you though uh you're you're
portraying a very Rosy scenario about
how well Democrats are doing you just
lost the house I mean your party was
just defeated at the house I get that it
wasn't as bad a defeat as it could have
been uh but it wasn't exactly a vote of
confidence in house Democrats
well what I'll say is that it was
historic over performance by every
single measure uh almost Beyond
comparison when you look
what does he mean though historic over
performance you lost the house you lost
Latino voters Florida became solidly red
New York almost flipped and sent a
couple congressional seats to
Republicans California even sent a
couple there is some weird stuff
happening here but yes of course they
just lie about everything and that's
what they do and yada yada I think you
got what I was selling today on the show
did you get it did I wrap this thing up
in a nice bow for you I think so uh all
right stick around for a cold close and
let's get to a couple
reubenreports.locals.com comments Tony
says Anand girohadras looks like the
Bollywood version of Mr Freeze oh that's
funny that's funny chill out
well that may I mean Schwarzenegger what
was he thinking how much did he get paid
for that
chill out give me what was another one
that he would say
I'm cold
it's freezing in here EK says if
anything from this year describes
Democrat privilege it's this whole
laptop story hunter gets a pass until
the election but the FBI raids melania's
underwear drawer yeah it's Democrat
privilege these and that's I get why
people so many people sell out to that
side because it's like they do kind of
win they do kind of win the machine you
know you can't fight City Hall The House
Always Wins I get why people are just
like ah forget it I can't take it
anymore you know people like Jennifer
Rubin she was I think of roughly sane
conservative and now she is a completely
bananas Progressive lunatic who can take
any position on anything I kind of
admire it at some level Amy says when I
first saw the Matrix I thought I'd
rather take the blue pill and just live
ignorantly and happily but I was in my
20s and voted Democrat coincidence isn't
that something you know there if you
haven't watched The Matrix in a while uh
there is that great moment where where
the I don't remember his name one of the
guys Cipher I think was his name Cipher
c-i-p-h-e-r in Matrix that sounds right
right where uh the agents basically get
him to turn on Neo because he doesn't
want to take it anymore he cannot live
knowing the truth anymore because the
truth is so painful to him right so
there's that moment they're sitting at
the restaurant and he just wants to eat
the steak and he wants to blissfully go
back to sleep was I right about Cipher I
think I got it not bad not bad
he just wants to go back deep he doesn't
want to deal with the pain anymore and I
think that's what that's what I'm saying
like a lot of people are just like I
will just stay blue pilled this thing
and the truth it's too scary and
fighting for for honor and and reality
that takes work man but just to sit in a
box and play video games all day and
watch porn and eventually they'll strap
something to your genitals and you're
never gonna get up and you're gonna eat
bugs
I don't think that's the point of being
a human but I'm old school what can I
tell you guys if you have not subscribed
do so on rumble.com it's rumble.com
reubenreport my full interview with
Byron Donalds who is a congressman down
here in South Florida in the the area
that was hit hard by uh hurricane Ian I
think this guy's got a bright freaking
future you know if there was some guy in
Florida that might become president this
guy might be the guy to replace him you
never know uh and I leave you I
apologize in advance we leave you with
wise words from Kamala Harris
well first of all
I acknowledge one must acknowledge
[Music]
we're in the community
the president has been clear on this
issue and on a very important issue in
addition to that important issue
when you see our kids and I truly
believe that they are our children they
are the children of our country
so when we went before indeed with pride
we planted our flag
and just think about it Affordable
Health Care is it it's about your health
and it's about more
here's the thing who doesn't love a
yellow school bus
whenever you're dealing with conflict
pull out a Venn diagram right and so you
know that's recircles
I'm Vice President of the United States
anything that I handle
is because it's a tough issue